The future of humanity seems insecure.
Rapid climate change, political division,
our greed and failings make it hard to look at
our species with a lot of optimism and so many
people think our end is in sight. But humans have
always thought they lived in the end times. Every
generation assumes they’re important enough to
witness the apocalypse and then life just goes on.
This is a problem because it
leads to short term thinking
and prevents us from creating the best world
for ourselves and our descendents. What makes
this worse is that we may actually BE living at
an extremely critical moment in human history.
To understand why, let us look at the
temporal window of humanity and ask:
When will the last human be born and
how many people will there ever be?
These sorts of estimates come with a
lot of uncertainties, so please take
them with a gigantic grain of salt. To get
a sense of how many people there will be,
let us see how many have already lived. Modern
humans arose some 200 thousand years ago.
They were uniquely good at
making tools, telling stories,
thinking abstractly, planning and working together
in large groups beyond their close family.
Still there were not that many of us. Surpluses
in food were sparse, survival was hard,
life expectancy was low. It took us 150,000
years to grow to a population of 2 million.
Improvements were gradual and eventually
led to the agricultural revolution,
arguably the biggest change in our history.
This was when our numbers really started
growing. It took ten thousand more years to get
to 300 million. But that increase was dwarfed
by the industrial revolution. In 1800 there
were a billion of us. The human population
doubled in just 120 years and then again in
fifty. Today, we number around 8 billion.
In total, over the last two hundred thousand years
about 117 billion humans were born and lived,
and 109 billion also died. Which means that
about 7% of all humans that ever lived are alive
right now. As many as were born in the first
150,000 years of human history. Every minute,
270 babies join the party. But there are not just
more people, never before have we been as healthy
and well off, or lived longer. With growing
living standards our birth rates collapsed.
The UN estimates that around the year 2100
we will hit our population peak and there
will be 125 million people born each year.
It is pretty unlikely that birth rates will
stay stable forever, but let’s pretend
to make our thought experiment simpler.
How many people there will be in the future
depends on when our species will die out.
And here we find a lot of uncertainties.
We are able to destroy ourselves through
our own inventions – but we are also able to
find solutions to avert catastrophic risk.
We can change the direction of planet killer
asteroids but we’ve also invented nuclear weapons.
We discovered antibiotics but also carry diseases
across the globe in a matter of days. Our
industrial system gave us an incredible standard
of living but also changed the atmosphere in the
process. It is very hard to say if human ingenuity
will prolong or shorten our species’ lifespan.
If things go badly our end could come
suddenly. But if we manage to avoid that,
we could conceivably stick around for a long
time. So every day we don’t destroy ourselves
may mean life for an unfathomable number of
humans. How many people are we talking about?
It depends on how far our
species is going to expand.
Scenario 1: Humans will never leave Earth
If we stay on our home planet, a good metric
to look at is the extinction rate of animals
that we get from the fossil record. The
average lifespan of mammalian species is
in the region of 1 million years, with
some surviving up to 10 million years.
Our close relative homo erectus
survived for about 1.9 million years.
Let us be conservative and assume that humans
will survive for a million years, which leaves
us 800,000 more years to dawdle away. Assuming a
stable birth rate of 125 million people each year,
this means there are roughly 100
TRILLION humans waiting to be born.
850 times greater than the number
of people that have ever lived.
This would make everybody alive today only
0.008% of all people that will ever live.
Think about where this leaves you. Instead
of putting you at the end of the chaotic
mess that was our past, it would mean you
live at the very beginning of something big.
The start of the human story rather than the
end. Doesn’t this feel incredibly different?
And now consider that this may be
an extremely pessimistic estimate.
If we match the survival time of the most
successful mammals, then our future numbers
rise to 1.2 quadrillion people that have yet to be
born. And even this seems far from our potential:
As the sun slowly gets hotter and brighter, earth
will remain habitable for about 500 million years,
giving so many more potential people
the chance to become actual people.
And now let’s begin to think big.
Scenario 2: Humans will leave Earth
We went from humans worshipping
the moon, to humans walking on it,
so who knows how much farther we can go? If we
don't die out within the next few hundred years,
ideas that seem outlandish right
now become serious considerations.
If we believe that we have a chance of
surviving for maybe millions of years,
then we could expand onto the other planets
or into our own artificial worlds. Life needs
three things: a surface, resources and energy.
Our Sun provides energy for billions of years and
there is so much water and material floating in
the asteroid and kuiper belt that we could
sustain many times our current population.
Instead of living on planets, we could decide to
construct our own artificial worlds and habitats.
With resources and energy so abundant, we could
try out different types of society and ways of
life. An interconnected civilization spanning the
solar system would create the basis of existence
for an absurd number of individuals, orders of
magnitude more than if we stick to earth, even
if it only existed for a few million years. This
future doesn’t have to be grim and dark as science
fiction likes to paint it. With quadrillions of
people waiting to be born, we will have billions
of doctors working on curing cancer, billions
of problem solvers working on ending poverty and
billions of video game developers making life
fun. More humans may actually mean more progress.
Another upside of leaving earth and spreading
out is that it becomes much harder for us to
become extinct, as you need a solar system
wide catastrophe to catch everybody.
So aside from nearby supernovae
or Gamma Rays bursts,
humanity would be relatively safe from
extinction, maybe for billions of years.
If we manage to survive for that long, slow
evolution or genetic engineering might split us
into multiple species, or we might intentionally
keep ourselves the same as we are now.
So to account for that, we’ll just talk
about people from now on, instead of humans.
Ok. Now let us think really big.
Szenario 3: People leave the Solar System
As enormous as the solar system is, it is just
one star system among billions in the milky way.
If future people can colonize, say, 100 billion
stars and live there for 10 billion years, while
each generating 100 million births per year, then
we can expect something like a hundred Octillion
lives to be lived in the future. This is a 1 with
29 zeros, a hundred thousand trillion, trillion.
We can spin this up as much as we like. The
Andromeda Galaxy will merge with the Milky way,
adding another trillion stars for us to settle.
Red Dwarfs stay active for up to a trillion
years and future civilizations might even find
energy for their habitats around black holes.
A sufficiently advanced civilization of our
descendants might even try to reach other
galaxy groups. While these numbers are mind
blowing, they may underestimate the number of
unborn people by many orders of magnitude. If we
divide the total energy available in a galaxy by
the average energy needs of a single person,
then we get a tredecillion potential lives.
A million, trillion, trillion,
trillion potential people.
Conclusion
Hopefully what has become evident is that
if we don’t kill ourselves in the next
few centuries or millennia, almost all humans
that will ever exist, will live in the future.
Which brings us back to us, in the present.
We exist at a highpoint of human history,
with incredible possibilities at our grasp.
Technological, environmental and societal.
What we do matters for all the
people who do not exist yet.
So while it is not en vogue to think
about humanity's long term future with
optimism – or to think about it at all –,
maybe this has given you a bit of perspective.
If we screw up the present, so many
people may never come to exist.
Quadrillions of unborn humans are at our mercy.
Even if we go with fairly conservative estimates,
the unborn are by far the largest group of people
– and the most disenfranchised. Somebody who might
be born in a thousand or even a million years
deeply depends on us today for their existence.
This is why it is important to think about the
distant future and why our presence is so crucial,
why it matters what we do today. One day the
last human will be born. We don’t know when.
But if we change our perspective from
us living at the end of the human story,
to us living at the very beginning we can
not only build a wonderful world for us
and for them but also for
countless numbers of others.
HUGE announcement: we are launching Kurzgesagt in
six more languages! Arabic, Brazilian Portuguese,
French, Hindi, Japanese and Korean, on top of our
English, German and Spanish channels. To bring
new perspectives and a love for science to as
many people as possible – especially to some
languages that are underserved because
it is not profitable to translate to.
If enough people watch our new channels, we
hopefully can run them for many years to come!
This is where we need YOUR help. It takes us a
lot of time, effort and yes, money to translate
our videos properly and run so many channels
– so to make this sustainable, please help
us spread the word!If you are a native in one of
these languages, share our videos on social media
and tell your friends and family – make people
in your native language aware that it exists.
This multi language expansion is
supported by Open Philanthropy,
an organization that tries to do as much good as
possible. They want to help us spread awareness
of science, and ideas for how YOU can help
humanity thrive. Their values align with
ours in many fundamental ways so we are going to
work with them on more projects in the future.
So please help us spread the word
– and thank you for watching.